what has been your approach to playing
this oh so strong
woman you know she really is so amazing
she's strong and she's also flawed and
that was what would
which makes her real she's a person that
you know has very strong conviction
she's like most of us women that work
and really believe in something that we
do in the work world and at the same
time we have a family
and you know that's one of the things
that intrigued me about the project was
that she's trying to do that thing we
all do
where we juggle we juggle and you know
so
it was it was many things it was
somebody that i felt like the project
really
kind of um delivered a great message
which is really you know entertainment
is to be entertaining but at this point
in my life i want to
be involved in something that that
matters and so it had that and then it
also
has a lot of humor and it has a lot of
like i was saying
the struggle of the working mom and you
know
you you just see that not everything is
perfect
she is completely like the the bows are
not tied up nicely
yeah god bless that she comes from the
right place she really comes from the
right place she's just
clumsy about some of it but the word
rebel
is truly one of my favorites in the
english language because it has that
hutzpah and that moxie but it isn't on
the takedown of other people
and that's where i draw the line like
i'll make my own mistakes
let me not hurt you along the way if i
can help it
and rebel just kind of says it all so
thank you katie seagal for joining us
today so we can talk about rebel that
airs
on thursdays at 10 p.m on abc it is
all the rage all the talk and i'm just
so happy for you to take on
another iconic role no
thanks drew
[Music]